عندما يضرب زلزال كبير تكون النتائج
كارثيه اضرار واسعه وضمار كبير طال البشر
والحجر مدينه انطاكيا بمقاطعه هاتاي في
جنوب تركيا واحده من اكثر المناطق تضررا
بالزلزال هنا عبق التاريخ حيث يمتزج
الحاضر بالماضي فالمدينه على مفترق طرق
للعديد من الحضارات القديمه وتحمل اهميه
كبيره لما تسخر به من معالم تاريخيه
مسيحيه واسلاميه صمدت على مر العصور لكنها
لم تستطع ان تقاوم شده الزلزال وتوابعه
دمرت الشوارع الشهيره في المدينه القديمه
بالكامل وتعرض كثير من الابنيه للتلف او
الانهيار وتحول بعضها الى انقاض
مسجد حبيب النجار بانه الصحابي الجليل ابو
عبيده بن الجراح بعد فتح المسلمين
لانطاكيا في عام
688 ميلادي تومه ركام تغطي قاعه الصلاه
فيه ولم تستلم الرسوم الداخليه والكتابات
على الجدران من الاضرار لم تفرق المحنه
بين احد على بعد مئات الامطار لحقت اضرار
ايضا بالكنيسه الارثوذكسيه اليونانيه التي
شيدت في القرن الرابع عشر
مدن تركيه اخرى فقدت اجزاء من ابرز
الاماكن التاريخيه فيها من بينها القلعه
التاريخيه في غاز عنتاب ومسجد يعني جامع
الاثري بمدينه ملاطيا الذي تعرض للانهيار
ولم يتبقى سوى اجزاء من جدرانه قائمه ومن
عنتاب الى شقيقتها المحاذيه لها في شمال
سوريا حلب طالت الاضرار مواقع اثريه
وتاريخيه ابرزها قلعه حلب التي يعود تاريخ
بنائها الى القرون الوسطى حدث تشققات
وتصدعات وسقوط لاجزاء من الاسوار في
القلعه
المدرجه في قائمه مواقع التراث العالمي
وتقع سته مواقع تصنفها منظمه الامم
المتحده للتربيه والعلم والثقافه يونسكو
ضمن التراث العالمي للبشريه في المنطقه
المتضرره من الزلزال